in 1914 when Europe got a bit worse the
British royal family headed by King
George V at the house of sax Coburg and
gotha opted to change its name this
changed saw the British royal house
become that of the House of Windsor this
change of name wasn't so clear-cutter
many others were put forth which raises
the question why did the British royal
family change its name and why did it
change its name to Windsor specifically
so as many of you will know after World
War One kicked off the British public
weren't exactly in a pro-german mood and
as the war continued this dislike of all
things German grew and given that the
British royal family had been German
since the Hanoverian Dynasty took the
throne in 1714 there were some in
government that were worried that
anti-german sentiment would soon become
anti-monarchy sentiment which was a fair
concern since Britain's first Sea Lord
the Austrian Prince Louis of battenberg
was forced to resign When The War kicked
off in 1917 after the Russian Emperor
was made unemployed British Prime
Minister David Lloyd George urged the
king to do two things one renounces
German and Austrian titles and two
changed the family name to something
more or British the king didn't want to
do this because Royal houses weren't
something that you would traditionally
rename on a whim but he didn't want to
get himself sad so he reluctantly agreed
King George personally wanted to take
the name Stewart to emphasize continuity
with the last non-german Royal House
Lloyd George said no because picking the
name of a house that was overthrown and
also one whose descendants pressed their
claim on the throne during times of war
was a bad look as such Lloyd George
called up all of the previous living
liberal Prime Ministers to come up with
a new name to get the king to agree the
first was Tudor which was vetoed by the
king since he felt that it was
associated with head slicing religious
turmoil and despotism plantagenet was
rejected for being too French whereas
York and Lancaster were denied because
of their association with Civil War and
insecure rule so why was Windsor put
forward well the name was chosen by the
king's private secretary Lord Arthur
stanfordam whilst he and the royal
family were staying at Windsor Castle
Stamford and realized that Windsor was
the suitable name for these reasons
first Windsor Castle had been in the
possession of the English and later
British royal families for about 700
years at this point second it was also
the title of Edward III who did the most
British thing of all he invaded France
and third Windsor was an entirely
British place with no negative
connotations Lloyd George agreed and
with a bit of encouragement so did the
king he signed a proclamation declaring
that the royal family had adopted the
name Windsor and the royal family had
renounced their German titles and awards
which for the British people politicians
and newspapers was enough to convince
them that the royal family was no longer
German but was instead a now
fundamentally British Institution
I hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons James
bisonet Kelly moneymaker Sky Chappelle
call show wolf Jerry lambden Jordan
Longley Adam Stalter Marcus Arsenal YN
hockey Spencer Lightfoot rod D Martin
words about books podcast kept inside
augustaf Swan Marvin Castle commune
Winston K wood boogly Wiggly Daniel to
be in Miss izet Aaron the white Corey
Turner the macquapa Alex Schwinn Anthony
Beckett Coppertone Maggie Paskowski she
went in spinning three plates and
Charles the first